yo tout le monde ou re tout le monde si
vous êtes là c'est que vous venez de ma
vidéo avec la les i sur survive earth
bêta 3 donc à une sorte de slider en
multijoueur donc vous pouvez jouer
jusqu'à 4 je vais vous montrer tout de
suite comment faire pour y jouer donc
logiquement et vous aurez téléchargé le
jeu et hamachi si ce n'est pas fait les
deux liens sont dans la description le
premier pour télécharger le jeu et le
deuxième pour télécharger à mâcher alors
une fois que c'est fait donc là vous
avez tout simplement le jeu et avant de
lancer le jeu vous allez devoir aller
sur à mâcher alors moi ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais cacher mon ip
parce que j'ai pas vraiment envie de me
faire pirater ou quoi donc je lance
quand même hamachi donc voilà on se
retrouve ici donc là effectivement je
suis dialoguer etc
mais quand vous lancerez pour la
première fois ce sera comme ça une fois
que c'est comme ça vous appuyez tout
simplement sur le gros bouton ici marche
et vous attendez que ça se connecte donc
on attend va attendre un petit peu on va
attendre que ça se connecte le jeu est
tout simplement là il n'y a pas de souci
bon ça m'a un petit peu de temps un plus
ou moins bon sachant que j'ai une co de
merde ça m'étonnerait pas que ça vienne
de là mais bon voilà je suis co donc ici
le petit zizi et le les eagles ce sont
deux salons de réseaux qu'on a créé donc
ce que vous ferez vous jeu logiquement
vous n'aurez pas ces réseaux là vous
ferez réseau créé un réseau une fois que
vous serez là vous l'appellerai comme je
voulais je sais pas par exemple je vais
l'appeler tuto sur vipers mot de passe
vous mettez chez pas un deux trois
quatre et confirme pas un deux trois
quatre
en faites-vous ensuite vous faites créée
voilà une fois que le réseau est créé
vous avez tout simplement donner à vos
amis le nom du réseau et le mot de passe
donc la c 1 2 3 4 les mots de passe vos
ami e iront dans réseau rejoindre un
réseau ils taperont ici l'idée du réseau
donc c'est hutteau sur vipers et en mots
de passe ils taperont 1-2-3-4 bon là si
je rejoins ça fait un truc bizarre voilà
vu que c'est moi qui ai créé le réseau
je suis déjà d'office dedans une fois
que ça se sera fait vos amis
apparaîtront là comme ici on voit mais
devine on voit vince young boys choc
ils sont là une fois qu'ils seront
dedans ça veut dire que c'est bon vous
êtes relier vous pourrez ensuite lancer
le jeu donc comme ceci alors j'espère
juste que ca va pas sauter je vais
vraiment ses frappes ce in game ce sera
plus simple
alors attendez là justement d'avoir un
petit écran noir
vous relancez tout simplement le jeu
hop je relance rap dans le tac voilà une
fois que vous êtes là vous faites start
serveurs donc là ça c'est celui qui au
sto logiquement qui en est là ça celui
qui fait l'hôte de la partir c'est à
dire qui a créé le salon sur un machine
et donc ses amis ont rejoint qui doit
faire ça les autres vous allez voilà
donc je disais les hôtes vous n'irez pas
dans serveurs mais vous irez dans
creator non pardon dans sa dent start
non lieu d'aller dans serveur vous ayez
donc client est ici vous taperez
l'adresse ip de la personne qui est
censé host et c'est à dire la personne
qui a créé le salon hamachi donc qui a
créé la moit hutteau sur gamers
j'ai mon ip marqué juste la bombe à la
je cache évidemment mais ces types et
qui est notée jusque là je devrais la
donner à mes trois amis pour qu'ils
puissent me rejoindre donc l ip qu'elle
à l'amont la gd flouté mais elle est ici
vous devez tout simplement elle est
juste à côté du gros bouton arrêt en
fait vous la donner à vos amis et vos
amis quand ils sont sur le jeu ils
devront tout simplement la rentrée là où
j'ai montré juste avant où il avait
marqué serveur client une fois que
ceux-ci se sera fait vos amis et bien
vous verrez vous de toute façon en tant
que hôte vous avez juste à aller sur
serveur et vous attendez il y aura
marqué voire un sur quatre et vos amis
ils vont nos clients ils rendent
l'adresse ip ils rejoignent et y aura
marqué bas 4 sur 4 si ça a marché
et puis voilà en tout cas tout est
résumé dans la description si vous
n'avez pas compris ce que je peux
comprendre ça peut être plus ou moins
claires sont les gens je comprends qu'un
des paquets pas compris je crois qu'il
n'est pas bon que j'ai pas compris
allez dans la description lisez ce que
j'ai marqué énormément tout est clair et
puis j'aurais même mis des petites
images pour vous aider et voilà ça
devrait aller si vous avez des soucis
n'hésitez pas à me demander si ça marche
pas chez certains c'est normal c'est à
dire que des fois il ya des sortes
d'incompatibilité entre deux personnes
par exemple je sais qu'avec mes mais
devine qui est en suisse on n'a jamais
su pourquoi mais même des zombies sur
black ops ou quoi on a 200 de pingu quoi
c'est n'importe quoi donc là c'était un
choc du cou qui hébergeait et puis voilà
en tout cas j'espère que tu tôt vous
aura aidé on se retrouve bientôt dans
une nouvelle vidéo
ciao tout le monde pis